およろしくお願いします
ケワーノダンマパダの五七ダンミニのテーピス
テーサンサンパンナシーラーナン サンアッパマーダヴィハーリナン サッマダンニャーヴィムッタナン マーローマッガンナヴィンダティ
テーサンサンパンナシーラーナン アッパマーダヴィハーリナン サッマダンニャーヴィムッタナン マーローマッガンナヴィンダティ
意味なんですけど サンパンナシーラーナンっていうのは
シーラーっていうのは戒律のこと
生き方のことですね 生き方には何の間違いもなく
完全ですということで
いわゆる戒律を完成しているということで
戒律っていうのは体と言葉の行為ですね
我々は体でやっていることと
言葉でやっていること
単純でそういうことなんですね
そこで間違いを起こしちゃうと
戒律を犯したことになりますね
間違った言葉を喋ったり
間違ったことをしたりするとね
そういうわけで 戒律っていうのは体で行う行為と言葉で行う行為が間違いはない
すごく完成しているんです
それで その二つの行為を完成すると
それで戒律を完成したということになるんです
そういうふうに理解した方が
すごくしっかりすると思います
なぜならば 戒律といえば
ものすごいたくさん項目がありまして
それぞれの宗教での戒律もまた違うし
同じ仏教にしたっても
それぞれ自分勝手にいろんな戒律があったりなかったりもするし
あるところで正しいというものは別なところで間違っているというしね
なかなか決まりられないんですよ
道徳って何やっていうことはね
はっきりしないんですよ
でも明確に客観的に具体的に人の生き方を見ると
それで二言葉でまとめてみると
体の行為と言葉の行為なんです
だから体と言葉を守りなさいというぐらいの話なんです
体と心を守っておけば
それで戒律を完成していることになるんです
誰かから誰かから聞く必要ないんですよ
自分が自分の体を持って悪いことをしない
悪いと思うものは微妙なことでもやらないことにする
言葉でもって喋る場合は
悪いと思う言葉は微妙にでも悪いと思ったものは喋らないようにする
その二つだけ守れば あの何億の項目ある戒律っていうのは別に全部守られてますよ
そういうことですから
すごくわかりやすく理解することはできると思います
サンパンナシーラっていうのはこういうふうなことで
きちんと道徳戒律を完成している人
人々 アッパマーダヴィハーリナン
ヴィハーリっていうのは生き方ですね
まだ それはアッパマーダによるもので
不放逸 不放逸ということは
過去現在に悩んだりしないで
時間スリップは起こさないで
今の瞬間の出来事はしっかり知って生きることなんですね
だから生きているということは
今の瞬間で生きていることは生きていることであって
なかなか人間にそれは難しくて
人間は過去か未来に生きているんです
過去と未来は存在しないものだから
結局は自分の頭の中で妄想しながら生きているんですね
そうすると 今の瞬間でやるべきことができなくなるし
頭は一向に良くならない
頭に情報入りません 過去のことを思い出しても
それは情報じゃないんですもう
ただの観念だけなんです
将来のことを思い出しても
それは実在する物事ではありません
だから 実在しない頭の中だけで起きる観念的な概念的な世界で生きているというね
いわゆる麻薬中毒中なんですね
すごい麻薬使っている人だったら
座っていてもこちらにいることではないんですね
自分がどこにいるか自分でわからないという
で そういうことでいるならば
いくら時間経っても いくら時間経っても
自分の頭の中の概念観念の中で時間無駄にしている
いわゆる物事は停止しないし
私が寝ているんだからそこまで待ってくれと言ったってもね
世の中何一つは待ってくれません
全て停止なし動いてます
変化して変わっていきます
それで自分もたとえ夢の中で酔ったままで妄想の中で生きていたんだからといって
物事は変わって変化していくんですね
だから自分にはその変わる世界に適応できないし
知らないし 何が起きているのかと知らない
だから 妄想して生きている人にとっては永久的に無知という状態になるんです
考えて考えて何か発見するということはできないんです
だからそれをやめた人ね
過去に生きることもやめて
将来にも生きることをやめて
今の瞬間の物事をちゃんとしっかりと認識する人がもう全て知っているんですね
だから そういうとこをできるまで心を上達させなくちゃいけない
これには結構訓練が必要になるんですね
私たちには認識という機能はあるんだけど
それがずっと正しく機能しないんですね
我々の頭は過去のものならとっくに終わったものならよく知っているという風な錯覚なんですけど
過去のものを知るために
これ起きている時情報を入れておかないとね
残念なことに起きている時は情報を入れてないんです
この出来事が 出来事が起きている時も情報を入れてないし
ほとんど寝ている状態でなんとか何とか入っただけのことで
その出来事を終わってから
頭の中で知識として処理するんです
だから現実とは我々の知識はほとんど関係ないぐらいかけ離れたものになるんです
だから そのかけ離れた事実とかけ離れた知識をまた固めて固めて知識だ
知ってるんだという態度になるんです
だから知っているのかと
聞きたくはなります お釈迦様は知らないんだよと
誰一人も それで我々は認識
知識 認識するという機能は持っているんですけど
これがまだ正しく認識しないし
過去のものでなければ認識しないし
過去のものであっても
過去のものというのはどこかの時間で現在に起きてくれな
起きるものだからね それは現在瞬間である時ははっきり見ていないし
だから現在瞬間で見ておいて
それ終わってから理解したっても構いません
理解するための時間かかるんだからと
とりあえず今データ集まりますよと
言って 現在の瞬間にデータをきちんと集めて
このデータは何なのかというと
はっきり判断できるんです
その時その出来事終わってますけどね
終わってるんだけど こういう出来事があったということは認識できます
次の認識の時に また現在データを集めて
またそれを処理して またこういうことが起きたと
だからその場合は一部一部であってもはっきりデータ知ってることになります
だからそれもしないんですね
現在の瞬間でデータ正しく集めるということは我々しない
しかし生きてるということは認識機能していることであって
だからすごい矛盾というか
変な生き方なんですね
知ることが命であって
知ることが生きているということなんですよ
で 皆様はそんなに大したことはない
この建物ほどの価値がないんですよ
肉体には 生ゴミでしょうに
だからもう生ゴミなんの価値もない肉体なんですけど
違うところがあるんですよ
生ゴミよりも建物よりも
どんな高価な物体よりも
違うところは物事を認識しているんですね
都庁のあのでっかい建物は何一つ認識していないんです
すごい高いものかもしれませんけど
人間の体よりは でも何一つ認識しないんですね
だから認識するということが生きているということで
が 認識していないんですね
特に 認識機能は働いています
何を認識するかというと
存在しないものばっかしで
過去か将来か ありともしないものは認識したっても
生きることには何の役にも立ちません
だから認識する機能ですが
無知ということになるんです
だから知というものはあるものが生命であって
生命は無知ですという文章になるんです
生命は無知ですと言えば
生命に知がなしと こういう言葉になるでしょうね
そちら辺で微妙なんですね
なんか微妙というと矛盾的な単語じゃないんです
だから知るものは命であって
命たるものは知ることはしないという
その場合は正しく如実にありのままに知ることはしないということで
ですから 知ってはいるんだけど
その知っているものは事実ではないということになるんです
そのややこしい この矛盾的な
もうまるっきり間違っている生き方を変えるということは
仏教で推薦しているんです
だから全然形而上学的なものを言っているわけじゃない
形而上学的なものっていうのは無知な人の哲学なんですね
魂あるかないかとかね
宇宙は有限か無限かとかね
そういうふうなものは無知の人の作業で
過去か現在のことを考える人の作業で
過去か現在を考える時点でもう無知ということになるんです
その作業を この間違っている作業をやめて
如実にあるままに それからこのようにそうマヌシカーラというね
もうまあすごくありのままに見る
その能力身につく それがアッパマーダという不放逸ってことになるんですね
そうなってくるとサンマダンニャ・ヴィムッタンという状態になるんですね
サンマダンニャというのは正しく知ってということ
アッパマーダだったら
知っている情報はそのまま知っているんです
そのまま情報を知っていると智慧が現れてくる
それが智慧というんです
知そのものなんですよ
我々も知識というかね
知識で言えばたった一つの単語で知というね
knowledge とか知るとかね
知るということなんですけど
我々にも知るというその機能はあるんだけど
正しく知らない 嘘知ってるだけの話で
それでありのまま見てみると同じ知る機能なんですよ
しかし事実を知っている
だから嘘知ってる人と事実を知っている人っていうのはかなり差が違うんですよ
それで我々は嘘をついたっても何か理解しているんです
それが知識というんです
それで事実を知っている人も何か理解するんです
それを智慧というんです
仏教のパンニャーはそういうことで
我々も妄想したい放題
過去のことを妄想すると
なんとか結論に至る場合あるでしょうね
頭で考えて考えて あ なるほど
こうなってるんだとかね
偉そうに結論に至るでしょうね
わかったわかった こういうことであると
我々わかったわかったということは知識であって
それは存在しないデータから得た知識と理解なんです
不放逸の生き方で存在するデータから得た知識と智慧なんです
だから知と知識 知と智慧という
知という 知ということだけは
知るということだけは同じなんです
そういうんだから この不放逸の人は当然智慧が得るんです
智慧を得た人が解脱するんです
智慧を得た時点で解脱するんです
それは何なのか なんで解脱するんでしょうかといえば
例えば知識によって我々は執着するでしょ
知識があればあるほど価値観入れちゃって
良い悪いと物事に判断入れて
あれが欲しくてこれが欲しくないというふうにあって
こういう状況を変えなくちゃいけない
辛抱しなくちゃ 合掌しなくちゃ
あれこれとやら感情ができてきて
我々は束縛されるんですよ
例えば この国はさらに開発しなくちゃいけないんだぞと思っちゃうと
もう自由がなくなるでしょうに
開発しなくちゃいけないんだから
もっと綺麗にならなくちゃいけないんだぞと自分に対して思っちゃうと
もうそこで自由がなくなるんですよ
綺麗になるための作業をしなくちゃいけなくなるんですね
もっと金持たなくちゃいけないんだぞと言ったら
その時点で自由がなくなるんですよね
家族はもうすごい大事だ
楽しいんだとかね と思っちゃうと
そこで家族から離れなくなっちゃうんですね
だから 存在しないデータから
まあね 偽装ですね 偽装したデータで得る知識
知で知ることで 偽装したデータを知ることで知識が生まれて
すごい束縛 執着と苦しみが生まれてくる
そちらには憎しみも恨みも苦しみも何でもあり
戦争も戦いも武器を作ることも持つことも全部あり
それはすべて偽装したデータから出来上がった知恵の世界なんです
データ偽装しないで ありのままに知ると
知識ではなくて知恵が生じるんです
だから正反対です 知識と知恵は
だから知識の一欠片も役に立たないんですよ
本当は  一欠片といってもほとんど役に立たない
場合によって偽装 まあする必要ないんだと思ったデータは知識になっても
それはもうそのままでしょうね
まあそういう人っていうのはすごい少ないんですが
大体みんなデータ偽装するんですね
だってデータ取ってないんだから取ったのように振り回わないと
見てないのに見たのように振り回わないと
聞いた聞いてないのに聞いたのごとく振り回わないと
振り回るためには偽装するしかないんですね
だって頭はずっと過去か現在で将来でしょ
だからデータ入ってないんですよ
それ言いたくはないんですね
それで偽装するんです
それで知識が生まれる
結果として執着と苦しみ
戦い 争いという煩悩の世界
輪廻の世界が現れてくる
だから同じ単純な法則で
それでデータを偽装しないで
ありのままにとってみる
何もさぼることにしないし
ごまかすこともしない
余計に自分好き勝手に価値判断を入れようともしない
価値判断を入れたということは
過去か将来に行ったということなんです
これはこれから高く売れるぞと思った途端
価値を入れてるで それは将来の妄想なんですよ
今土地を買っておけば
あと二年で売っちゃえば
いきなりもう千万もうかるんだぞとかいうふうな考え方でしょ
普通の世界では 今いいんですよ
今土地等買うんだったら
もう見る見るうちに値段上がってるんです
もう一度経済状況は悪いなのに
またバブル時期になるようなもう兆しはあるんです
私は言うものは大体五
六年 七 八年かかりますからね
結果出るまでは だから嘘やと思うかもしれませんだけどね
必ずそうなるということは言えませんよ
将来のことだからね まあとにかく今土地を買っておけば
一年経ってから売っちゃうと
千 千万円自分の手にあるんだぞと
銀行に置いておいたっても全然ダメだからね
お金は 株買っても危なくてしょうがないんだからね
だからこの方が確実に儲かるぞというね
まあこれはまあ私の私語じゃない
皆様大体そういうふうに考えるんです
だからそういうふうにデータを取ることっていうのは
もう事実ありのままに見ているんではなくて
将来という妄想概念で偽装しているんです
データを 偽装して知識になる
そうなると苦しみが生まれてるんですよ
それは分かったんだけど
これが一番簡単に儲かる手っ取り早い方法やと
これだったら解釈部になったって知ったもんか
そんなのはと でも肝心なことお金がないと
今 今買っておけばいいんだけど
これだったら万々歳なんですけど
あら お金がないということになるでしょうに
それからあらゆる苦しみが生まれてくる
[背景音楽]でお金手に入ろうとしてね
もう何とかしたりして人殺す可能性もあります
そういうことで この知識の世界からはもうそういう苦しみが生まれてくる
智慧の世界は逆になるんですね
だからデータそのままありのままに見ると
知識ではなく智慧が生じる
智慧が 知識で苦しみが生まれるんだったら
智慧で安らぎが生まれてくるんです
知識で執着生まれて苦しむんだったら
智慧で執着がなくなるんです
で それでありのままに見ると
データどう見られるのかっていうことは
お釈迦様が何の隠すこともなく
誰もその研究やってもないのに
そのレポートは明確に何一つも隠すことなく発表しているんです
過去に行かないで 将来に行かないで
データが起こるその瞬間で
この実際の瞬間で 現在の瞬間で物事を観察すると
本当にこの世の中は何の何ものか
自分で本当に何やと価値判断入れないで見ると
捏造しないで見ると どういう世界でしょうかっていうことは
お釈迦様の発見なのに
隠しておけばよかったのに
それを隠しておいてないんです
これは教えてあげませんよと
私が発見した秘密やとは言ってないんです
秘密はないんだ 全部言っちゃいますよと
研究上だったらほとんどデータ隠すでしょう
秘密にするでしょう 研究論文発表するのは大学研究所だけですよ
大学よりはもうはるかにむっちゃお金使って研究ばっかりしている
もう色々あらゆる会社がありますよ
データは発表しない 何か誰か日本人裁判にかけられたでしょ？あのアメリカのデータ盗んだとか何とか言って
そうやってアメリカで研究したいと
だから自分が何十年も出入りして研究したところ
自分が作った研究したものなんですけど
それ覚えてるでしょ？ほとんど
逆に言えば自分がやったことだから
それだけでもどこかで言ったら
もうあんたもうもう裏切り者やとかね
あの 何て言いますか データ盗んだとかね
いう世界ですからね  [背景音楽]だから世の中ってのは
例えばこれが私がこの研究はもう二十年目やってますよと
この研究実験 全て私が私がやったもので
だから私は他のところでそこで講演したってば何が悪いのかと
私の知識でしょうと その場合は知的財産にならないんですね
いえいえ あなたはこの会社で仕事をしたんだと
だからあなたの知識は会社のものであるというということになっちゃうんですね
大学研究所だけは一応発表することを目的で
これはもうただ何か立場作ることだからね
私はこれぐらい研究しているんだぞとかね
褒めてもらいたいんですよ
それだけ ガキです それでノーベル賞でも決めたらえらく喜んじゃうんです
褒めてくれたと ほとんどノーベル賞では結構結構大金もらいますけどね
それでそんなにそんなにお金もらってよかったそんなにあまりないんです
褒めてもらったことにえらい喜びを感じるんです
で 実際の社会 大学研究所のベースにある一部的な変な社会ですからね
実際の社会ではもう研究して発見発見するものは言わない
そういうことで だから一番大事な真理発見したならば
それは自分で握りしめて隠しておいてね
それから特許を取って金儲かるとかね
そういうことっていうのは
まあブッダはしなかったんです
だから仏教では密教は成り立たないんです
それはヒンドゥ教で邪教であることなんですね
密教と言った途端 異教じゃなくて邪教なんですね
まあ宗教の他宗教という単語を私は一応礼儀的に使いますけど
やっぱり論理的に言えば
他宗教は他宗教で邪教は邪教で
世の中の宗教は我々は他宗教other religionsという単語で認識しなくちゃいけない
しかし 邪教っていうのはね
あってはならないという意味にもなります
だから仏教の中に密教が現れると
もうこれは明らかに邪教なんです
他宗教の場合は秘密あるんだぞと言ったら
仏教いうのはね あんた方おかしいんじゃないの？なんかやばいところでもない
あるんじゃないかなというね
隠さなくてもいいでしょうと
バレたらまずいところあるんじゃないかなというふうにからかうだけで
イニシエーションしなかったら教えませんっていうのはおかしいんです
イニシエーションということもヒンドゥー教のしきたりなんです
仏教ではイニシエーションというのはないんです
ヒンドゥー教でバラモンの男たちが十八ぐらいになると
大人にするという儀式があるんですね
バラモン人にするという
それでバラモン人を集めて
呪文とか歌って 一つ首に糸をかけておく
首ではなくて 肩も肩に一つ糸をくぐってそれをかけてあげる
今日からあんたはバラモン人だと
神の子やと その他の人々とは違いますよと
そのある特定のカーストだけで起こる出来事で
バラモン人が宗教の聖職達だから
違うカーストの人々はバラモン人を通して神様とのコンタクトを取らなくちゃいけない
カトリック教と同じなんです
神様と直接はコンタクトを取ってはいけないんです
で 神父さんがそれやってくれないと
だから昔あったんです
今もあるかもしれませんだけど
あなたの罪を全部何て言いますか
免除しましたとかね 証明書を出すんですよ
教会から  免罪符  免罪免罪状
免罪符という  免罪符 だからそんなのってできるのか
人間にはね お金あげればいいんですよ
お金か何か協力 昔よくよく政治的な戦いではね
で 戦争するわ もう人は国を取るは
ヨーロッパの方でね だから自分が王様として認めてもらいたくて
もうあれが悪いことばっかりしちゃったならば
それからもうなんとかしっかりしたいということで
免罪符とかなんとかもらったりして
それはもうお金くれるくれる人にももう発行し
発狂発行したりして それで本当に罪がなくなるのかどうかね
組織でそうやってあげて
そこでその組織に怒られたら天国に行けないんだぞというね
相撲を送ったら もうその人々はそのままもう地獄に落ちる
なぜならばそこはもうコンタクト連絡先だから
連絡先というんですかね
そこはこの まあ人間の情報はプロセシングして神に報告するところだからね
報道機関だから それでもう人間は大変な厳しい状況に陥っちゃうんですね
そのシステムというのは
一応ヒンドゥー教ではものすごいじりじりとあったんですけど
やっぱりインドではね
それなりの自由あったんだから
それに逆らったり もうそんなことあるわけないでしょうとか言ったりする人も当然いるし
でもヨーロッパみたいな汚くなかったんだから
ものすごいいろんなルター派やらね
プロテスタント派やらあれとか
そこまでは分かれることはなかったんですね
向こうは喧嘩して戦争しなきゃ分かれることはできませんだからね
イギリス教会とまた別でしょうし
権力から逃げるためなんですね
逃げたって もし本当に神様っていうのはもうアホで
人の言語わからなくて
バチカンで喋っているラテン語しかわからなかったらどうするのかと
わかりませんよ 神様っていうのはたくさん言語を知っているかないかと
今の情報から見るとなんか頭が悪そうに見えますけどね
あるいは当時で喋ったヘブライ語かもしれませんし
アルマイトでしたっけ
それはイエス様がそういった言語でね
その言語以外知らなかったら大変なことになりますけどね
今のローマ法の話もわからなくなりますけどね
あの人 ドイツ語とラテン語とかいくつかのヨーロッパ言語しか知らないんだから
もしそうだったら大変なことになります
イギリス教会とかね 頑張っても連絡はいかないんです
まあだから だからやっぱり戦争して人殺しして分かれる羽目になったりもする
まあインドでもそういうすごい複雑に宗教のやり方ありまして
喧嘩はしないんですね
みんなもうそうでもないでしょうということでね
まあとにかくバラモンのカーストの人々は自分たちで権力を握っていたいんだからね
もうカーストシステムをいまだにものすごいじりじりと社会で生かしておくんです
それはもう変えようとは全然しません
それでバラモンの若い子が一応一人前になってくると儀式を行って
あれプールななんとかっていうんですけど
あの完成になりましたということで糸をつけてあげたりはする
それがイニシエーションなんですね
それから彼にまあ ヴェーダ聖典やら何にでも自由に知識にアクセスできるし
勉強することも儀式を行うことも
一人前でいろんな儀式に参加することもできるし
そこまでは たとえ無職でも年下だったら入れてくれないんです
イニシエーションしない限りは
だから仏教ではそういうものは成り立たない
ありえないんです 仏教では密教はない
とにかく密教もイニシエーションもありえない
そこでヒンドーの世界ででも関係なくね
バラモン教も関係なく修行する人々もいたしね
じっと修行して長い間修行すると大体尊敬されちゃうんですね
あまりにも尊敬されちゃって
あまりにもなんかすごい力があるんだなとか
みんなに言われて認めてしまっちゃうと
バラモン人に無視できなくなっちゃうんです
あの人はバラモンカーストでもないでしょうと言ったっても
すごい仙人として生きているんだから
ただ畑 田んぼ仕事をして
牛を殺して肉を売って生活しているバラモン人とすごい聖者みたいな感じで修行している
大したことないって言えなくなっちゃう
言ってはいたんですけどね
お釈迦様対して あんた方はハゲ頭で誰が認めるかという
サイキの人々は お釈迦様
お前ら何やっている人でしょうかと
ただの人を騙すは お金取るは
あれやこれやこれで立派と思ってるんでしょうかと
嘘を言うは普通の一般人だからね
そういう修行して 随分聖者として仙人として崇められた
崇められた人々のことをね
後で問題になりまして
じゃあそういう人々もバラモンとして認めなくちゃいけないんだと
生まれは聞いてはいけませんと
いうちょっとした例外もあります
だからその場合でもイニシエーションということになるんですね
それで この再び生まれるという単語はヒンドゥー教の単語なんです
セカンドバースということは
ヨーロッパよりこちらの方がすごく古いんです
インドの方は これは三千年前からもうどんどんどんどん広げてきたヴェーダ文献では
ヴィジャというね という単語があるんです
ディっていうのはセカンド
ジャっていうのは生まれたということで
セカンドバース セカンドバースというのは
バラモン人の子供がイニシエーションを受けて神の子になることなんです
それでバラモンカーストでない人々にはセカンドバースは不可能です
できない 認めてくれない
そこら辺 中東の砂漠で始めたのはそういうことなんです
今日朝思いましたけど
私は髪の毛剃りながらね
一応電気カミソリでやるそうとね
それで電気カミソリでやって
あれで何か電気カミソリの場合でも何か塗る何かあるでしょ？液体は
あれ塗っちゃうと もう皮膚の脂的な全部なくなっちゃって
なんかもうカサカサ状態になるんですね
で そうするとこのちゃんと電気カミソリで髪が切れるという話で
まあろくに切れませんだけど
ただ皮膚に悪いだけで
それ塗っちゃうと 私の頭のてっぺんのところはもう髪は一応薄いんです
で そこをやると もうそこら辺だけすごいスムースにもう感じちゃうんですね
ここら辺なんで丸い形でスムースだなと
すぐ思い出したのは あら
このカーディナルたちもこっちら辺全く丸く剃るんです
頭のてっぺんのところ
あのポープも剃ってます
丸 円の形に そちらにまた帽子をつけて隠しておくんです
あれって何やと 知ってますか？知らないでしょ
で 昔なんとか民族かのいて
この頭に穴を開けるんです
昔そういう民族結構有名ですけど
ちょっと今日は名前思い出せません
人が一人一人と  ヨーロッパの民族
そうそうそう すごい野蛮的で
まあ怖い人間で  バイキングかな
ケルト人じゃないですか
ケルト人じゃない  ケルト？ないない
もっと戦争の好きな あと調べるかは分かりません
とにかくいてね その人々は頭に穴を開けるんですよ
であのアフリカでもどこかどこかでそうやって穴を開ける部族はもう最近までいたんですけどね
で この頭蓋骨に穴を開けておく
それからもう皮膚を切っちゃって
そこでもう骨だけなんとか道具で切って穴あけて
それそれでまた傷跡に治療するんです
それで普通にもうもう隠れてますけど
頭蓋骨の中に穴があるんです
で 何のことなくやるんですよ
なぜかというと このここら辺
何かいじっちゃうと死んじゃうでしょ
脳の場合はそんなないんですよ
痛くもないし 痛いのは皮膚だけでしょうし
それはそんな大した痛みじゃないでしょ
こちら辺切るよりはこちら
そんなに硬くはないし
だから皮膚だけちょこっと切っちゃって痛い痛いって言ったらそれで終わっちゃうし
次に骨を掘るだけで骨を掘っても掘っても痛くないんですよし
骨一部取って捨てたっても俺知らない本人は
それから傷跡をつないでおく
そういう習慣があって
それがイニシエーションでもあって
この特にこの宗教的な意味があったんで
そこで穴を開けておくと
異次元の神々の情報っていうのは直接入るんだと
だから神とのコンタクトなんです
これはこの連中がやってます
このみんな見栄張ってやってる
この今はもう日本も狂ってるでしょ
もうクリスマスで 全て原始人の習慣なんです
まとめてまとめて カトリック教っていうのはすごいかっこいいでしょ？あらゆる式典あるんだからね
もうあるはあるわ もう十字架を切る方法もまた宗教によって違うしね
何でもかんでも決まって決めてあって
これ一つも別にキリスト教の独自のものじゃないんです
いろんな彼らが異端異端と
殺した人々から学んだもんなんです
それで新しいシステムを作ったりとかね
まあそんなもんでしょう
文化っていうのはね で
神父さんに聞いてもわからないでしょう
なんであの頭剃るのかとかね
普通の人はやらないでしょうね
カーディナルとかね それぐらいのビショップとかね
世間話は置いといて えーと
ブッダはありのままの事実を見て
捏造することをやめて
そうすると世の中って何や
自分って何やっていうことはわかったんですね
今までもう麻薬 麻薬中毒でもう過去にいたんだよと
将来の夢ばっかり見ていたんで
事実を知らなかったと
事実を知ったぞと 本当はこんな夢で描いた世界とは違うと
これはどういう世界かというところは堂々と発表したんですね
だから この仏教というものはそういうものなんです
ものすごい堂々と四種具足しながら
これ四種具足であると言って師匠態様を発表するんです
そこでこの捏造したデータで知識のみを持ってる人は
なんかガチャガチャガチャガチャ
なんだそんなものはとか何言ったってもね
これとはブッダの世界は違うんです
面白いことは なんでこの妄想だけで生きている
知識だけで生きている人々は
ブッダの説法を聞いてわかったようなふりをするのかと
わからないでしょう なんで過去か将来のことしか頭に入れないし
知る生きたい生き物なんですけど
知ることしないでしょう
だから たとえ仏典読んでも
妄想で理解するでしょう
なんでみんなわかったようなふりをするのかということはね
そこはお釈迦様が言うのは
私が言っているのは真理ですからね
事実ですからね 捏造してもしてもよく捏造しきれませんよと
いくらでも もういくら隠しても隠せないものもありますね
この世の中で  例えば韓国人には日本人になりすまして日本でいることはできるでしょう
中国人にでもちょっと二
三ヶ月間日本語を勉強しちゃうと
もう日本人よりものすごい上手になるんだから
体が苦労しているのは
あの あの 日本語の文章にあるこのアジア的な部分
いくら入ってるでしょう
あの動詞がちょこちょこと過去と現在に変化するし
それだけなんですけども
アジアの言語みたいな
過去 過去完了形 現在 現在完了形
未来 未来完了形とかね
そこまではできてないんですけど
でもその微妙な文章文法でもちょこっと中国人にはちょっと把握できない
それって単純だからすぐ勉強するんです
そうするともうすごい見事に日本語使ったりはする
それで中国人にはいとも簡単に日本人になりすまして
日本人みんなを騙すこともできる
では私が同じことをやろうとしたら騙せますかね？私も本当は日本人ですよと
名前はこういう名前ですよと
できないでしょ？すぐわかりますからね
だから隠せる事実もありますけど
いくら踏ん張っても隠せない
ものを世の中にあります
イラクのフセインがね
大量破壊兵器は作っていて
もう人間じゃないんだと
この石原さんとかね あんなのは何やってるのか
人間じゃないでしょとかね
堂々と言ったら 石原さんいうものは全て世界一真理だと思っている人々は
なるほどそうだなとかね
それで でもやっぱりこれはねつ造したデータだととかね
あとでどんどんバレていくでしょうね
隠せなくなっちゃうんです
まだ日本にそのデータ入ってないみたいですけどね
日本以外は世界はみんなもうねつ造したデータで無駄な戦争をしたっていうことは知ってます
だからこの事実 データを変えて嘘をついてごまかしてねつ造してっていうのは
ある程度ではうまくいくんです
特に戦争中は全部 あの情報戦略でしょ
情報で 情報で一般人をごまかす
騙す 騙すと お互いに だからブッサンがね
あのアルジャジーラでしたっけ
もう爆弾落としたいと言ったことも
やっぱり気持ちは私わかりますよ
それに別にもうだから何やとかね
このもうデモやる必要ないんですけどね
だからブッサンが自分たちがデータをねつ造してねつ造して
世界的なもうマスコミチャネルで
もう ABC やら CBC やら何でもかんでも
それで BBC までね 世界のニュース
我々は教えているんだぞとか言って
そちらで嘘だけ流していて
他の人々には他のニュースチャネルは全く存在しない
ゼロ そこでアルジャジーラという辺遠いなところで
またもう衛星サービス始めちゃったんだから
これで爆弾落としたいなと思うのはね
それは気持ちはわかりますよ
それさえなければいかに楽かということでしょ
だからこのアルジャジーラであろうか
アメリカのニュースであろうか
もうみんなこの自分勝手にデータを変えて変えて
いろんなことをして 出して
人を騙したりはする しかし
まあどこまで騙すのかといったっても
どこまででもということは無理なんですね
どこかで真実見えてくる
観察能力があれば そんな苦労しなくたってもすぐ見えますよ
別に調べなくても 一つの記事を見ると
この人は取ってるデータこれだけで
これはこういう風に練り
練って練って練って作品にしているんだぞとかね
見ただけですぐ見えてきます
この本人が裏で何考えているのかとかね
そう見えて見えない人は別なデータも読んでみて
違う人々の話も聞いてみてとかね
という風に苦労しなくちゃいけない
そこで ブッダの教えはなんで我々は分かったような気がするのかというと
これ事実ですからね いくら自分の主観で概念で真理でない嘘で処理しよう処理しようと思ったっても
いくらか残るんです だからお釈迦様はもう何のこと遠慮なく堂々と言ってやれと
こんな反論したってもね
もう嫌や そんな話は嘘じゃないかと言ったって
堂々と言わせてくださいと
そいつらに言えないんだと
最初はちょこちょこと踏ん張るかもしれませんだけど
それからは控えるんだよと
これがそうでないとは言えませんよと
よっぽどの変人で頭がおかしくてね
もう完全イカれているんだったらまあしょうがないんですけど
微妙にでもちょっと常識があるんだったらもう負けることになりますと
そういうわけで この仏教はブッダの真理は堂々と言ってはいる
しかし 私たちは分かって言ってくれてるのに
論文発表しているのに
我々は悟りに至らないんですね
それがもう過去か現在に生きているんだから
知識しか生まれません
仏教を学んだっても知識しか生まれません
知識は苦しみしか作らないという
正しく不放逸を守って真理を正しく見ている人にとって現れてくるのは知識ではなくて智慧ですね
それはサッマダンニャ
正しくすると智慧が現れてきて
ヴィムッターナ 執着ではなくて解脱という状態になるんですね
例えば 全ての出来上がったもの
合成されたものは無常であるというのは発見した真理なんです
一切というか 一切の業
諸行無常だと分かったら
なんで執着するんですかね
執着が消えるんです その時
知識じゃないんです 智慧なんです
この偈で説明しているのはそれだけのこと
それでマーローマッガンナヴィンデティ
その人々のマッガン 道は
道っていうのは何者かということなんですね
その真理を知った人の道
真理を知った人の状況
状態 頭の中ということですね
どうでしょうかということは
マーラさんは知りませんよと
マーラっていうのは悪魔のことでね
別に悪魔っていう 俗世間でもよろしいんですね
俗世間は知りませんよ
あんた方はと 寝ている人々には
捏造したデータが正しいと思っているんだから
もう知るはずもないんだと
ということは 悟った人の境地というのは
概念持っている人には知り得ない
不可能です 知ることは
理解してやろうと思ったっても無理
完全にもう俗世間の基準とは関係なくなっているんです
それで全部意味はまとめたと思いますよ
テーサンというのは彼らのということで
彼らというのは聖者たちのことですね
どんな聖者たちかというと
まず戒律は完成していて
戒律といってもすごい難しいことではなくて
体と心の行為は間違い犯さない人々
アッパマーディヴィハリなんていうのは
普通の生活はちゃんと過去現在に走ることなく
今の瞬間の事実をそのまま観察していて
そうなってくると知識の代わりに智慧が生まれてくるんです
ありのままに見ることはできるんです
そうなっちゃうとどうなるのかというと
心は執着捨てちゃうんです
執着捨てたところで もう我々と普通の人間の生命とはもうまるっきり違う
どうしても理解できない状態になってしまうんです
言語の範囲は超える 知識の範囲をすべて超える
一切概念 概念可能な範囲すべて超えている
だいたい存在しないものでも
人間には頭だけで働いて理解することはできますよ
例えば無限という単語とかは決して経験じゃありません
頭の中で生まれるんです
で 論理的にも成り立って
もうそれであるのようになってしまうんです
実際あるかないかわからないんだけどね
いくらでも頭を働かせて
数学を働かせて 使って
で ほとんど数学ですけど
数学使っても存在するかどうかわからないものの存在も発見できる場合があります
ブラックホールの発見みたいなもんで
ほとんど数学ですけど
だから数学だけで でも後で調べることできたところで
なるほど見事に合ったぞとかね
アインシュタインさんでも言ったいくつかのことはね
ずいぶん後でしょ 発見したのは
その通りだと 今までは論理的にそういうことになるんだよという話だけで
そこで悟った人の境地はそういうふうにも至りません
数学的な思考で でも論理的にもう何とかして成り立つようにしようかなと思っても
それ無理ですよと 人間の思考はそこまでですと
と言われるとそこまでです
それがマーローマッガンナウィンダティという言葉で言っているんです
マーラが知らんと まあ単純な子供向きのたとえ話で言えばね
まあ魚っていうのは まあちゃんとした生き物なんですけど
水の中の世界しか知らない
陸上のことは知ることは不可能ですよ
まあ不可能といっても
強引にでも魚をちょこっと外へ出してみればね
陸上だからね 魚はそれでもそれなりの経験を受けるでしょう
それからまた水の中に入って
あ 陸上のことを知ってるんだぞと言うかもしれませんよ
でも 魚の世界と我々の世界っていうのはものすごい違うんですけど
その場合は 陸に捨てられた魚にとってはね
まあバタバタするだけで
もうもう呼吸困難起きちゃって
もう呼吸できなくて えらい怖くて
もう感触が最悪で体に
恐ろしい地獄みたい もう熱に浸っても
もしそれで昼だったら
魚にとって信じられない
よくもこの地獄に来てるんでしょうとね
この人々は だから魚から聞けば
君もちょこっと陸上に行ったことある？で
ありますよと どうでしょう
あれはもう明らかに地獄ですよと
秒でも良い感触はないんだと
体に触れる感覚は極端に苦しみ
それから熱はもう燃えるんだと
生命には生きていられる境地じゃないんだよと説明するかもしれませんだけどね
だから我々の陸上の話と魚の陸上の論文というのはかなり変わりますが
それでも魚はいくらかでも知ってるんです
それぐらいでも不可能ですよ
涅槃の強調することは
頭では 魚の陸上の論文の話がどうでも
それでもない それでも我々間違ってると知ってるでしょうに
それさえもできない もう知識の範囲
知る範囲はそれで飛んで消えてしまう
なぜならば 人間の知るということは
データを知らない 知らないことにすることが知ることにしてるんだから
無知が知にしているんだからね
[背景音楽]